[Music]
we brought you reports last night that
congressman adam kinzinger of illinois
had been seen crying again we promised
to get to the bottom of that story
members of congress are technically
speaking sent to washington to vote and
not to weep and so we thought it was
worth following up tonight we have an
update on that congressman kinzinger has
been spotted crying again according to
our sources in a place where you rarely
see tears in waffle house you're seeing
the waffle house location on your screen
if you look closer you will see adam
kinzinger clearly distraught crying
inside a restaurant that serves waffles
according to our sources it's unclear
exactly why he was crying a shortage of
boysenberry syrup said one
lynx patties were not available said
another
we can't tell you more
but if we see adam kinzer crying again
you will see it here first
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now